[Music]
good morning guys I am on full dad mode
today and I am actually extremely
nervous because it is monkey Cheetos
very first Jiu Jitsu tournament are you
ready
you are are you nervous
a little bit or just a lot
better I don't think you're nervous at
oh you're just you're just chilling
eating strawberries this morning
fine let me see a rash guard show
everybody your Spider-Man rash guard oh
they're gonna be like I didn't know how
to do Jiu Jitsu with the Spider-Man
that's crazy bones well anyways I'm on
full dad mode and he doesn't seem
nervous at all I think I'm way more
nervous not nervous in in the aspect of
the sport but like of being a good dad
so look I have to get everything ready
duffel bag got um his ghee because he's
doing a geek competition he has his
Nokia which is good gotta bring the
tripod because you gotta have the family
footage of how he did you know so that
when he's like older we can show like
the pics even though this is like a 1080
um but to show him the like pixelated
footage of then then I got all his
snacks so this is what I'm really proud
of because my bear I went to the store
before she left to hook me up so we got
Lunchables
we've got a backflips and I see all
these snacks monkey look at all these
snacks you'll be ready to go we got
Gatorade
we got Gatorade
there yeah there's even more over there
and we got water because you're thirsty
yeah and I made them some turkey
sandwiches with Hawaiian bread yeah I
did that yesterday because I want to be
prepared I don't want to rush anything
in the morning even though I feel like
I'm rushing already and you guys might
be wondering where's my bear well my
bear is on a bachelorette party
and on a trip that she booked like a few
months ago and obviously it centered
around The Bachelorette and this
tournament popped up so she couldn't
really cancel that because it's not
really her event you know but anyways I
think I have everything under control
just a little bit nervous I want to make
sure I'm a good soccer dad that's all so
I have everything packed in here
ready to go drinks snacks everything I
got the tripod for the footage let me
know if I'm forgetting anything ghee
nogi
and then uh I gotta bring a seizure
medicine cause we don't know if the
event's gonna go all the way past like
seven o'clock so we gotta have that and
uh we're ready to go you ready you ready
to do some Jiu Jitsu today no no you
just told me you were ready
it you did it are you nervous at even a
little bit no no I'm
not oh you're a lot nervous
I'll come yesterday when coach asked you
if you're nervous he said I'm not
nervous at all
no I didn't say that oh what did you say
okay well you know what you've been
training super hard
and yesterday we did an hour of Jiu
Jitsu I'm really proud of you and I know
you're gonna do so good
you want to pack so soon to Jesse now
yeah sure let's do it all right so we
came early which is good you always want
to be ahead of the time so there's no
rush you don't feel a lot of pressure
because you're gonna be nervous anyways
um still got another 30 minutes before
the doors open how are you feeling now
now that we're right here
still nervous what about eating all the
snacks does that make you feel better
a little bit do you remember your game
plan
remember it game plan that's so
important look at me Mr
okay Step One is what
sound snap down on what do you do after
the bath spin to the back yeah and then
what's the last move
yep over under With Your Hooks and good
job okay and then what happens if
someone mounts you what do you do
so proud of you mister
step on this scale they have to weigh
you
did he make way or you have to take off
clothes okay cool good job dude
49 pounds dude
that's very
inside of the dog to compete oh yeah
yeah there's so many mats so the way
it's organized is this one is ring one
three five two four six and there's even
like 10 12 14 all the way on the other
side and I'm glad we came early because
we get to camp out right here I get to
set up my little tripod and I'm looking
at taika's brackets and it's perfect
because both of his matches are at Mat
one so the number on the left is the mat
and the number on the right is the match
number so Matt one ring one everything
will be right here I don't have to move
around makes things simple in the later
I get to connect with uh all this other
you found another bottle cap okay bring
it over here
four okay he's been trying to collect
bottle caps so he's really excited
actually throw this away because we
don't know who that belongs it's gonna
be yucky and dirty okay we will only
collect the ones at home
yeah so he uh both of the match is gonna
be right here so I can set everything up
nicely and have our little base camp
have our snacks and food I even brought
camping chairs in the car just because I
didn't know what the whole scenario is
going to be like so I wanted to be comfy
because sometimes you don't know if I'm
gonna be the whole day you know when you
have like these competitions and I'm
really happy that I actually compete in
powerlifting quite a bit because the
structure is very similar like you know
you have like people in order and you go
platform a platform B so it's cool that
I get to like take some of the stuff
that I know apply to some of the stuff
that this guy's gonna be doing you ready
dude you're gonna be right here okay on
ring one
right there yep
yep that's Ring one
oh good job thank you for taking off
your shoes
yep right there
right there dude
yep
right there
you look like a natural
okay we're probably gonna have to get
off sooner I was gonna get kicked off
okay so this makes me feel really really
CUNY because a bunch of the other kids
at J uh JT JT is taika's uh teammate at
Titus school is also competing so the
minute he saw them he ran all the way
over there to say what's up to him so
now like those two twins right there
they're both wearing Cobra Kai hoodies
um now he feels like so much more comfy
in his nerves aren't so up here so it's
cool to have like a little Community to
compete with and uh the other kids are
also in his age group
um not in the same bracket because he's
in I believe novice which is like a
super beginner the other kids have been
there like a year or two more so it's
cool that like everyone gets to walk him
through the process even the parents the
parents like are the ones that told me
to like log into that link to see where
the brackets are and stuff like that so
that's how I even have this information
otherwise
um I'd be like super lost you know but
it's cool that I have this and then when
I hit bracket it zooms in even more like
which kid he's gonna be competing with
so I feel like I have a good grasp of
what's going on as uh the soccer dad and
I am still kind of nervous because I
don't want to mess things up I don't
want to miss the time because I wrestled
in high school before and there's times
where like they literally call you
they're like all right up next is Bart
and whoever and I'm like oh my God I
have a pizza in my mouth because they
move the matches up entirely because
those numbers can switch at any time so
I just don't want to mess things up but
I'm glad that the little monkey dude
right there wandering around
running with his friend feels happy
well I'm glad they're getting warm what
a great way to warm up
oh my God
you guys are getting warm
okay no more running dude come here
hey JT what how many competitions have
you done I don't know
I know how many blockets I have how many
brackets you have four four yeah I
thought you had a bunch of other
competitions before
I don't know how many competitions I
have because I had like a lot do you
have any advice to give to taika
oh there's five of us if you
did you hear that
I'm not saying you if you you have the
route alone
but if you lose you can learn more stuff
if you win you don't you go on West oh
okay did you hear that
you said just try your best and if you
win or lose it's okay because when you
lose you learn more stuff right yeah
okay good luck today mister
okay what's your game plan JT stay low
if I can stay low you know he's gonna
slam you
good nice
wow that's really good
tap tap tap okay Mount taika come on
taika
Doug what do you do how do you get out
push the hips push the hips get your
legs up yep good good
snap down right away snap down right
away yeah yeah go step down have you on
the head yep heavy heavy heavy
it's been heavy yep hooks in right away
hooks in right away so it'll fall up
hooks in right away
good good good
job monkey you guys are ready good job
JT I like your slam
[Music]
coach Justin James
[Applause]
I'm good
job good job
[Music]
good job
[Applause]
thank you
all right come on
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
oh my God
first of all I want to tell you monkey I
have never seen you fight so hard in my
life and I am so so proud of you
so proud of you you fought so hard for
all three minutes how do you feel Mister
you feel good
did you did the game plan work I saw you
do a snapdown so many times in the
beginning yeah
okay
love to him you'll be really rough I
loved it so you know all the the only
thing we have to work on now is when
someone uh when you're getting them off
you on the mount we know we have to work
on that and next time you're gonna win
but that was so good I'm so proud of you
I've never seen you train so hard before
good job Mister
[Music]
so we just talked to Coach
and Coach gave him some words of
inspiration which is awesome so the guy
that taika was grappling against
that other coach is coach's best friend
and that kid has been taking it
seriously he doesn't mess around and so
our coach still take up he's like to be
honest with you every time you go to
Jujitsu you kind of mess around a little
bit but he's so proud because he was a
beast out there so with only knowing a
couple moves he never gave up did you
ever give up
no you're working hard were you being
mean
we're being tough you had to be lean
into being tough right and we can see
try hard over and over and over and
never gave up never Pride so coach is
saying now you imagine you have that he
was crying yeah
that means they're too tough for him so
what coach is saying
so coach is saying if you use that
spirit in training and you don't mess
around the train anymore and you train
hard during practice you're gonna be a
monster you still have one more match
today okay I'm so proud of you I love
you
thank you
so I finally have some down time
[Applause]
I am so [__] proud of taika like
every time I think about it I actually
want to cry
because I have never seen him take
anything this seriously and
um you know one of the things when we
signed them up for this competition even
beforehand coach is telling us
it could be one of two results one
he knows what actual competition is and
he stops messing around in practice and
it turns on a fire or number two he gets
his ass wrecked so hard he never wants
to do Jiu Jitsu again so all of us like
you know both the team I mean both the
coach and the parents were a team and we
want to make the best decision for taika
and the coach is like you know what
let's do it attack it has a lot of heart
and the amount of art this guy showed
today it was it was really um it's
really moving for me because I've never
seen him try so hard in my life
and uh it makes me so [__] proud of
him so the fact that we like he turned
on something that we've been wanting to
turn on in a long time that we never
could
um through all the practices like we've
been here with them for like a year and
a half
um it's [__] cool it is [__] cool
to witness a side of taika that I never
knew existed and I think that's why all
the parents are cheering so [__] loud
you saw just one more match today and I
could have been prouder to me he won I
don't give a [__] this is like an
evolution in his childhood and his
upbringing you know like he's gonna have
hundreds if not thousands of Jiu-Jitsu
matches it's the first one and seeing
him unleash that especially in the
beginning he was like trying to get that
game plan snap down snap down snap down
so [__] proud if you're watching this
in the future taika I [__] love you
and you crushed it today
hey monkey you know what
you earned the medal
oh no no no no no no no no oh no oh no
no no no
no you ready to go get it yeah let's go
get it
he's so happy good job good job thank
you yeah
take a picture right after him okay
good job
good job mister
oh excuse me good job dude
what's that is that your first medal
ever yeah
you never get one where you worked so
hard good job wow
this is the golden one yeah all right
taiko's resting now we changed them into
his ghee because he still has one more
match and that's gonna be a gee one
and so far this the damage has been done
to the snacks I spent all not all night
but I spent last night preparing like
the sandwiches and he only ate one
I guess that's like what it's like for
Dad life because look at this and I
can't even eat it it's so delicious
they're ham sandwiches with mayo and
mustard on Hawaiian bread I want to eat
it so bad but I'm on a diet so I can't
really eat it and I'm looking at them
like you're not gonna eat these so he
had his Lunchables which is cool you
want a chocolate bar yeah
you have to pull it up can you pull it
out so yeah he's been eating just the
other side snacks obviously he's a kid
okay I'll open it for you so that's what
we have right now and then in about 15
minutes he's going up
[Music]
you're ready
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
come on
right now
[Music]
[Applause]
let's go
come on
[Applause]
thank you
good job
dude yay
happy to put in your chest on the head
right getting heavy scroll over under
you're just pushing him like this so you
need to get your chest on top of your
head if you had front headlock with your
chest on the back of the head you would
have every point every time so you get
everything going it's just little things
that we need to make a little tighter
the tiger that was amazing I just got
married
how did you feel about that match
huh good
huh
you did really good you got him in a
rear naked you were choking them from
the back
that was really good
the other guy was hard but one thing I
think that you have to work on is when
you put your belly on his head you got
to put heavy weight okay
okay I'll take a look I'll see if you
have another medal okay but come over
here
when you're when you um when you snap
them down make sure you put heavy on his
head okay that way you can turn around
you got it okay
[Music]
so this is incredible
taika Juan is very first metal in life
how do you feel Mister happy happy
was it fun yeah I feel tough it felt
tough do you want to do it again
next time we're gonna come and win what
you're telling me you want silver this
time but next time you want to come for
the golden oh this is awesome I'm so
proud of you
yeah
I got two
but I still got this one yeah what's the
funnest part if Falcon in this one I'm
not getting that that's all you want
yeah can you draw them on the back here
it's yours you could do whatever you
want you could put your name you could
put a heart you could put a monkey
I could teach you how to draw Monkey oh
you know who could teach a draw Monkey
no mama Mama's really good at drawing
Papa's like like okay I drive Mama's
really good they're really good at
drawing bunnies and you're really good
at Jiu Jitsu too
I'm so proud of you monkeys
okay we're talking about right next to
here we go right you're right but I'm
glad that you like this and I'm glad
it's so fun for you anything you want to
tell mama okay
you don't want to share anything over
your mouth dude that's disgusting
anything you want to share with Mama
about
your Jiu Jitsu match today your first
ever Jiu Jitsu tournament
nothing
but what does it say Naga Naga yeah
North American Grappling Championships
or Association oh this one is not good
yeah Zimbo
simbo
oh okay okay well now it's time to get
whatever lunch you want because you
earned it what do you want to eat
McDonald's what about pizza or anything
like that no oh Pizza you want pizza
can we eat it inside a restaurant you
want to eat at a restaurant yeah
yeah I deserve it yeah
you do you earned it okay let's go I
don't get
it I don't deserve no if you get a medal
you still deserve it but today you extra
deserve it you always deserve because I
love you mister
oh
oh by the way Mr Ronald
well the next time you compete it's
gonna be tougher
yeah it gets hard on her because
everyone gets better so that's why now
you know what training means and you
can't mess around in training I'm gonna
I'm gonna put my window down and it
throws up oh my God they're messing
around already
so we got home and then we instantly
took a nap both me and the monkey Cheeto
is tired and the champion
well we need you to sleep or else we
have seizures
put on his metal right away he's gonna
find a CUNY place to put it
and now we're gonna have ourselves a
good time and uh watch a UFC fight thank
you guys for hanging out with us while
we experience taika's first Jiu Jitsu
competition I'm sure there's gonna be
many more but I'm so proud of them
because I think today he elevated not
only his skills but his
um mentality and took one giant step in
his childhood I'm so proud of him I love
you Mr Man
oh